hemos visto imágenes como las del ataque
contra el hospital materno-infantil de
mariupol a pesar que los centros
clínicos no pueden ser atacados según el
derecho internacional humanitario
entonces por qué ocurre esto
bueno claro que yo no tengo no puedo
entrar en la mente del señor cutter pero
si uno fuera a pensar de esa manera
vamos
si criminal
habrían yo creo que dos objetivos el
primero sería para negarle el uso de los
hospitales y de iu para las fuerzas
ucrania eso entonces obviamente sería
debilitar las fuerzas y segundo también
espantar y crear terror dentro del
público para que se puedan a huir de las
ciudades y entonces sería más fácil para
las tropas rusas poder capturar y
mantener control de las ciudades donde
están bombardeando los hospitales que
como usted bien dice son los lugares más
protegidos en tiempos de guerra y en
otras guerras ha habido ataques contra
centros de salud y cuál es el impacto
que esto deja en la población civil
bueno en todas las guerras siempre han
habido ataques
porque sin querer sin propósito han
dañado iglesias
hospitales lugares cultural importante
etcétera pero lo que estamos viendo aquí
es algo que es
determinado y programado con todo el
intento de las fuerzas rusas así que eso
es eso es una gran diferencia comparando
lo que estamos viendo aquí hoy en día
con lo que ha ocurrido antes y ahora le
pregunto sobre otro tema porque polonia
le pidió a la otan que envíe tropas a
ucrania a través de una misión
humanitaria y de mantenimiento de paz
como la que usó para bombardear en
kosovo en 1999 sin embargo esta última
misión ha sido una de las más criticadas
de la otan por romper la norma
internacional de no intervención puede
entonces usarse una figura así para que
la otan entre en ucrania y cuáles serían
las consecuencias
bueno las consecuencias
empezamos por ahí porque la yo creo que
la razón principal por cual ese tipo de
ayuda humanitaria no se ha implementado
hasta este momento de esa forma directa
es precisamente porque quieren evitar el
riesgo de que los rusos se vayan con
enfrentar directamente con fuerzas de
otan porque de ahí eso ya se puede pasar
de control y nos encontramos en la
tercera guerra mundial